Hello everyone, my name is Fangji. I am
a senior ngraph engineer working at the
campmini Germany and in the last five
over five years I have been working on
both research and industry applications
of semantic web technologies and
currently I'm working in the area of
clinical trial and life science.
So let's talk about the problem we are
facing now. um clinical trial protocol
contains most of the some of the most
important information in drug
development. For example, it defines um
we who can participate in a study for
example and um what is the schedule of
activities, what evidence are generated
in the end and through this process
different standards were applied and to
make information consistent and
reusable. Um however these uh standards
are often applied in different systems
at different stages and each of them
builds own view of the study design and
making everything connected together is
currently um the human work and this is
hard to be reused again. So how we solve
this problem with our ontology based and
large graph based approach. I will
handle this to my uh colleague Misha and
he will give a more detailed
introduction of our approach.
>> That question is exactly where we
started. Hi, I'm Michael and I'm a
senior knowledge graph engineer at
Capgeemini. Over the last five years,
I've been designing and building
enterprise knowledge graphs across
different industries. I also have a
strong research background and have
published at the leading semantic web
conferences such as ISWC, ESWC or
semantics.
My part in this solution here was to
make sure that the knowledge graph
answers real questions and is aligned
with real information needs. Here's an
example of such a question. How did
protocol amendments affect the schedule
of activities? We collected those
questions before modeling anything. The
talk follows a single question end to
end covering extraction, terminology
resolution, core standard alignment,
reconciliation, graph ingestion,
provenence and expert review. We
deployed our solution in an enterprise
pharmaceutical environment and evaluated
it on real protocol content and with
real users. People get answers they can
trace and agents get structure they can
traverse. Getting there was not
straightforward and we will be glad to
walk connected data London through both
half of that story. Thank you for
listening.